no no no
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález segundo
informe de gobierno del presidente de
méxico andrés manuel lópez obrador el
mandatario de los mexicanos desde el
patio del palacio nacional rindió
cuentas sobre su gestión en una
comparecencia que estuvo enfocada en
tres temas fundamentales corrupción el
avance y la lucha de la pandemia del
cobi 19 y la recuperación económica y el
desarrollo del país que balance fue el
que dio el mandatario coincide la
realidad con la percepción que tienen
los ciudadanos que deudas tiene
pendientes el presidente de los
mexicanos para lo que resta de su
mandato como va mexico ese es nuestro
tema de hoy en france 24 para analizar
en el debate precisamente para hablar
sobre este tema vamos a invitar o hemos
invitado a aleida alavez ella es
diputada federal por el partido
movimiento regeneración nacional morena
y también es presidenta de la comisión
de puntos constitucionales nos acompaña
desde la capital mexicana también está
con nosotros
adame él es diputado federal por el
partido acción nacional pan también es
vicepresidente de la mesa directiva de
la cámara de diputados y también se une
desde la ciudad de méxico también está
con nosotros
-mario carbonera el corresponsal de
france 24 en la capital mexicana también
queremos conocer su opinión por eso los
invito para que dejen todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales france24 guión al
piso
y arroba sant y luego deje todo con la
etiqueta numeral el debate
efe 24 les quiero comenzar entonces
dándoles un dato según una encuesta del
diario el financiero la aprobación de
gestión del presidente mexicano tiene
una aprobación del 59 por ciento de los
mexicanos y es desaprobada por el 40 por
ciento de los ciudadanos
ese es como el punto de partida de este
gran análisis donde vamos a tocar varios
temas y quiero comenzar con mario'
nuestro corresponsable de la capital
mexicana para hacer rápidamente mario'
resumen y un balance pequeño corto de lo
que dijo el presidente esta mañana allí
en el palacio nacional en la capital
mexicana
gracias y buenas tardes un saludo a los
invitados pues el presidente como ya lo
mencionado centró su discurso en el
manejo de la crisis el manejo que se ha
hecho de la crisis tanto sanitaria como
económica y destacó desde luego pues la
presencia de sus programas sociales dice
que 23 millones de familias han sido
beneficiadas con estos programas
sociales lo que les ha ayudado a
aguantar esta crisis derivada de la
pandemia de covite también puso énfasis
en la austeridad dijo que son 560 mil
millones de dólares los que se han
ahorrado de gracias a recortar los lujos
los excesos en el gasto del gobierno y
bueno también se refirió al manejo de la
pandemia de coronavirus al señalar que
pues en el país no ha faltado las camas
en los hospitales para quien requiera la
atención y señaló reiteradamente que
vamos en el camino de la recuperación
que ya se comenzaron a recuperarlos
empleos y que la economía volverá a
levantarse esto es un poco la visión que
él expuso esta mañana esto a grandes
rasgos son varios ya vamos a comenzar
hablando por el tema de la corrupción
que fue el primer tema que tocó el
presidente el mandatario dijo que
durante su gestión se han ahorrado 560
mil millones de pesos mexicanos por la
gestión que han hecho en torno a este
tema para los mexicanos el tema de la
corrupción va mal el 50% lo cree así y
bien el 27% veamos que fue lo que dijo
el mandatario sobre este tema
pronostica que la crisis económica
provocada por la pandemia sería
transitoria dije
que será como una uve
que caeríamos pero que saldríamos pronto
afortunadamente así está sucediendo ese
gobierno no será recordado por corrupto
nuestro principal legado sera
purificar la vida pública de méxico no
hemos emprendido persecuciones facciosas
ni venganzas políticas
pero tampoco encubrimos a nadie
y permitimos la impunidad ya se acabó la
robadera de los de arriba vamos
directamente al análisis aleida alavez
en ciudad de méxico su opinión sobre
este primer punto la corrupción lo que
ha dicho el mandatario las cifras que ha
dado y la opinión que usted tiene sobre
este tema
muchas gracias muy buenas tardes y es un
honor estar en esta evaluación del
segundo informe de gobierno del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador y
como él bien lo dijo el combate a la
corrupción es una de nuestras
principales premisas para edificar un
nuevo costado del que las contabilidades
de este sea precisamente cero impunidad
y por lo tanto plata porque ha hecho la
unidad de esa financiera que depende de
la secretaría de hacienda al recuperar
dineros que habían estado involucrados
en delitos de cuello blanco de grandes
cantidades de cuentas bloqueadas se
detectaron es un flujo de completa
corrupción es algo que revela como que
aún mira en esta pista que no permitía
la justicia y sobre todo en esta parte
en la que se iba dineros
y era finalmente el erario dineros
públicos a cuentas particulares eso es
algo que estamos documentando con mucha
puntualidad son miles de millones de
pesos se han respetado bajo este esquema
marco adame también hay en la capital
mexicana su opinión gracias a santiago
el informe lo vamos a analizar en la
glosa que ordena la constitución hoy
sólo tenemos un mensaje político y lo
que se ha dicho hoy es cuestionado por
una realidad que es absolutamente
desalentadora combatir la corrupción es
combatir la impunidad no hacer
escándalos mediáticos porque esos no
generan justicia generan beneficios
políticos lo que estamos esperando los
mexicanos
que quienes tengan responsabilidades
sean presentados ante la justicia y que
se sometan a las leyes sólo así habrá
justicia y sólo así se combatirá la
corrupción mientras tanto no hemos visto
todavía una clara determinación de que
eso suceda mientras quienes abusaron del
país siguen al margen de la justicia es
decir señor adame que desde su
perspectiva la lucha contra la
corrupción no es como la está planteando
el presidente en este informe y también
pues hay que hablar de esos escándalos
recientes que incluso involucran a
familiares al hermano del presidente que
han presentado un vídeo en donde hay
allí como una trama que está en
desarrollo y que está investigando la
justicia mexicana la corrupción no va
por buen camino entonces en este
gobierno
hay que poner a los delincuentes al
alcance de la justicia no de la pantalla
de televisión para ser sujetos de un
linchamiento público se trate de quien
se trate este no es un tema de
familiares de amigos de cuates como se
dice en méxico es un tema de procesos
del debido proceso penal de las
instituciones del poder judicial y de
procesos que deben ser llevados con
todas con todo rigor para que se combata
la impunidad y eso no ha sucedido aún
la ley da su opinión la impunidad un
tema importante es que queda sobre la
mesa
bien pues vivieron completamente no son
escándalos mediáticos son procesos
judiciales que no estábamos ni siquiera
acostumbrados a ver en las anteriores
administraciones en donde había un pacto
de impunidad para proteger a los
políticos en los niveles más altos a
pesar de que estuvieran involucrados
caso de la estafa maestra el desvío de
recursos de dependencias donde pues
ahora ya hace iniciar las
investigaciones para que esos dineros
regresen al erario es algo que se está
viendo con toda apunto de procesos
judiciales a veces no se finiquita por
problemas en las leyes que no facilitan
el cómo puede hacienda hacer valer a la
fiscalía general de la república toda
esta información y por eso no avanzan
como se quisiera pero de que empezó a
hacerse valer eso es un hecho
les voy a dar el dato de los recursos
que se han bloqueado en cuentas que se
encuentran totalmente anómalas por la
cantidades las cantidades que fluyen en
ellas y esto es algo que no habíamos
visto insisto y es un combate a la
corrupción real y ya hubiéramos querido
que detuvieran en las administraciones
pasadas que se la pasaron haciendo
negocios en todos los poderes en el
legislativo ahí está lo que está
declarando él el propio director de
pemex en donde los sobornos confían en
el poder legislativo de la manera más
burda más significa cuando pues había
toda esta modalidad de estar repartiendo
dinero y no antes actúan desde veces no
lo han podido explicar públicamente como
hacían para tener todas estas reformas
que hicieron que casi se privatizará
pemex y cf que ahora este gobierno está
recuperando como empresas del estado y
que estamos tratando de no
de otros países por ejemplo en la
producción de nuestra gasolina y por eso
se están haciendo proyectos de la
refinería de dos entonces es un país
distinto a partir de que llega a andrés
manuel a la presidencia de la república
en cuanto al combate a la corrupción
-mario carbonell nuestro corresponsable
en la capital mexicana ya lo decía yo la
encuesta realizada por el financiero da
una percepción de los mexicanos que el
tema de la corrupción el 50 por ciento
va mal y el 27 por ciento dice que va
bien y que la gestión está haciendo bien
manejada en torno a este tema como es la
percepción en general de lo que se vive
allí en el día a día de los mexicanos
más allá de una encuesta de un medio de
comunicación cómo es la percepción que
nos puede decir usted al respecto
pues sin duda este tema de los vídeos en
donde ya lo mencionaba la diputada
aleida del caso de emilio lozoya ex
director de pemex ha dado mucho de qué
hablar
en la sociedad lo que se ha revelado de
presuntos sobornos a legisladores en el
sección anterior para aprobar las
reformas del ex presidente en peña nieto
es algo que está en en los comentarios
cotidianos de la gente pero también lo
que tú ya mencionaba santiago del vídeo
del hermano del presidente de pío lópez
obrador recabando recursos en efectivo
presuntamente para la campaña de 2018
aunque fue años atrás pero bueno para el
movimiento y por la respuesta que ha
dado el presidente en este sentido de
que no son casos iguales no se pueden
comparar ha dicho el presidente lo
cierto es que ambos ambas situaciones
están sin duda en las charlas de café en
los comentarios cotidianos de la
sociedad porque el tema de la corrupción
pues es algo que méxico
arrastrando durante décadas y es la
principal oferta la principal promesa
del presidente erradicar la corrupción
él ha dicho que ya no hay corrupción en
la parte de arriba en la cúpula del
gobierno pero que aún hay camino por
andar en las las esferas más abajo del
de la administración pública esto es
algo que la población tendrá que medir
tendrá que aprobar o desaprobar no
solamente las encuestas como ya lo
menciona sino también en las próximas
elecciones las de 2021 en donde se
renovarán 15 estados de la república es
decir el gobernador cambiará en el 2021
y ahí también pues va a ser un buen
termómetro de cómo la sociedad está
percibiendo la gestión de lópez obrador
en el tema más importante para él que es
la corrupción claro ya lo decíamos las
encuestas que estoy citando son
simplemente una muestra no es el total
de la opinión de los mexicanos es
simplemente una muestra pero lo que dice
mario'
me parece que calza bien en este punto y
es que esas elecciones de medio término
en su mandato pueden servir de
termómetro para ver cómo están evaluando
su gestión en cierta medida los
ciudadanos mexicanos debo avanzar con
otro tema porque quiero abarcar las tres
los tres ejes que sitúa el presidente a
lo largo de su informe y el segundo tema
es el tema de la economía esta misma
encuesta del financiero dice que la
economía está muy mal que el 61% de los
mexicanos lo cree y así claro el
escenario es complejo no solamente para
méxico sino para la economía mundial y
para todos los países de américa latina
el 19% de los mexicanos dice que la
economía va bien comienzo entonces por
marco preguntándole su percepción hay
que entender que el escenario y hay que
ser justos también que el escenario es
adverso para la gestión que está
teniendo el presidente porque ningún
mandatario tenía previsto tener que
cerrar la economía de los países por más
de 5 meses para poder hacer frente a la
pandemia
si santiago primero saludo a mi
compañera aleida alavez
tal como se dijo en el caso de la
corrupción si méxico es hoy un país
distinto dice ella pero no mejor y el
caso de la economía es un ejemplo muy
claro
el país a partir del inicio de este
gobierno empezó a tener consistentemente
trimestres con el crecimiento económico
la pandemia vino a agravar esta
situación de tal a tal de tal tamaño en
tal medida que no se conoce una crisis
igual desde 1932 el problema es que los
temas de empleo de apoyo a las fuentes
de trabajo especialmente a las pequeñas
y medianas empresas y a los trabajadores
que tienen en riesgo o han perdido su
empleo hasta por 12 millones y medio de
personas muchos de ellos en la economía
informal no han recibido apoyos de hecho
en las mediciones internacionales somos
el país que menos ha aportado recursos
para apoyar a las fuentes de trabajo y a
los trabajadores que perdieron su empleo
los recursos se han destinado a otras
prioridades
en la agenda del gobierno federal y no
en reactivar la economía
como debe de ser la ley da su opinión
sobre el tema económico que le está
faltando a méxico para marchar teniendo
en cuenta este panorama de la pandemia
del cob y 19
si como bien lo dicen es un escenario
económico muy desfavorable por la
pandemia pero este problema se atendió
precisamente en esas dos vías en como
hacíamos que el el impacto fuera el
menos posible pero también como se cuida
la salud que es lo primero de las
personas y por eso las medidas que se
tomaron obviamente están teniendo sus
repercusiones esto de detener un poco la
economía para priorizar la salud de las
y los mexicanos es algo que se discutió
ampliamente y que lo hemos estado
discutiendo en todos los poderes de este
país no sólo eso yo creo que también se
afianzó la parte en la que el estado se
asume responsable del bienestar de las
personas
se hace todo un planteamiento en el que
se busca que cada de siete de cada diez
familias reciban un apoyo del gobierno
federal ya sea mediante la pensión
universal adultos mayores que ya es
constitucional que la acabamos de
establecer como una obligación del
estado el apoyo a las personas con
discapacidad el apoyo a estudiantes de
tal forma que todas las personas
insisto siete de cada diez familias en
el país reciben un apoyo del estado esto
ha incrementado la capacidad de consumo
y la caída no ha sido tan estrepitosa
como en algunos otros países que
obviamente están priorizando la
actividad económica a la salud de las
personas entonces yo creo que estamos en
un camino de mucha responsabilidad con
respecto a las vidas humanas pero
también atendiendo que la economía pues
no caiga
lamentablemente es en escenarios
catastróficos hasta el 10% del producto
interno bruto pero es una realidad que
va más allá de un manejo responsable se
ha mantenido la recaudación fiscal eso
también es importante no se hacía mucho
por tener una reputación fiscal efectiva
y en este año a pesar de la pandemia se
mantuvo esa recaudación fiscal
aleida desde fuera de las fronteras
mexicanas lo que se percibe de este país
es que le está apostando nuevamente a
ese tratado de libre comercio que fue
firmado con cara de con eeuu y vuelve a
hacer las mismas críticas que le hacen
algunos países a mexico y es que está
muy enfocado en eeuu que sigue
manteniéndose como su principal socio
comercial y no mira tanto hacia la
región de américa latina esa es la
percepción que hay desde desde fuera de
las fronteras mexicanas tal vez le está
faltando este impulso de abrirse un poco
más a méxico para poder darle otro
impulso a la economía del país para qué
de pronto de una manera más rápida
lo que nos informó el secretario de
relaciones exteriores en la reunión que
hubo con mi bancada el grupo
parlamentario de morena en la cámara es
que precisamente no sólo es garantizar
que sea con estos tres países del norte
el afianzar estas relaciones comerciales
también se está buscando los enlaces con
américa latina y el caribe de tal forma
que con ellos se busca inversión en
diferentes materias creo que la que va
avanzada es con las universidades de
diferentes países de latinoamérica en
donde se está fortaleciendo la
investigación en todos estos rubros de
la salud y se está trabajando a nivel
internacional pero también en este
intercambio de conocimientos de
investigación con las universidades de
américa latina' ese es uno de los grupos
que yo recuerdo ahorita nos compartió el
secretario pero efectivamente
necesitamos observar que haya esa visión
de una integración más sólida y firme
con
américa latina' eso es algo que vamos a
estar observando y que va a estar dentro
de nuestras preocupaciones los próximos
meses
marco adame su opinión para cerrar el
tema económico le hago esta misma
pregunta méxico estaba volviendo a
concentrarse y a focalizar todo su
esfuerzo económico en el aspecto de la
relación con eeuu y con este acuerdo que
incluso el mandatario habló sobre este
acuerdo comercial alcanzado esta
renovación alcanzado con eeuu y con
canadá y está dejando de lado su región
natural que es américa latina
centroamérica por supuesto que es el
vecino y el caribe
sí y santiago desde luego que la nueva
edición del tratado méxico-estados
unidos-canadá es importante pero también
es no menos importante la
diversificación y en ese sentido méxico
necesita voltear a otras regiones del
mundo y de manera muy sentida muy
especial
américa latina para generar una serie de
acciones de conjunto en esta gran región
que puede lograr mejores negociaciones
si se generan estrategias regionales
ahora déjame decirte los apoyos
económicos directos a los que se refiere
la diputada a la vez son importantes
pero si no se apoyan las fuentes de los
centros de trabajo las fuentes de empleo
no habrá crecimiento y yo difiero de lo
que se ha mencionado hace un momento por
ella no se detuvo un poco la economía
estamos ante una contracción económica
de 12.8
por ciento según cifras del banco de
méxico y una caída del pib del 18.7 por
ciento en el segundo trimestre del año
esto es de un impacto brutal y también
la recaudación fiscal ha caído de tal
manera que no estamos ante un escenario
sencillo más bien muy complejo y
necesitamos definir políticas públicas
económicas con otra orientación con otro
rumbo para que se genere la recuperación
que tampoco será tan inmediata como lo
señaló el presidente en su mensaje
todavía no hay manera de asegurar que
será una v es una la recuperación que
será lenta y puede ser más lenta y no se
toman las decisiones correctas y eso es
lo que estamos pidiendo desde mi bancada
en el partido acción nacional además que
hay que tener en cuenta que también sus
socios comerciales principales también
están tratando de apalancar sus
economías para salir adelante eeuu y
canadá también
en problemas económicos entonces no será
tan fácil esa recuperación económica
pues esto fue lo que dijo el mandatario
de los mexicanos en torno al acuerdo
comercial alcanzado con canadá y eeuu
en estos momentos de crisis el acuerdo
que firmamos significa impulsar las
actividades productivas conseguir más
inversión extranjera crear más empleos y
lograr más bienestar para nuestro pueblo
en este contexto debe verse mi visita a
washington para entrevistarme con el
presidente de donald trump quien nos
trató con respeto y lo más importante
elogió a nuestros paisanos que viven y
trabajan honradamente en eeuu de américa
avanzó con el siguiente tema que trató
el presidente en su discurso el tema de
la salud la pandemia el avance de la
pandemia del cob y 19 de acuerdo a la
encuesta del financiero la gestión del
presidente mal muy mala está en el 36
por ciento una bien o muy bien hecha
gestión ronda el 33 por ciento aquí hay
opiniones un poco más encontradas entre
los mexicanos lo que es cierto es que
méxico está entre los países que más
cantidad de casos está registrando fue
uno de los países que se demoró más en
tomar medidas preventivas si lo
comparamos con otros países de la región
que empezaron a tomar medidas de
bioseguridad de una manera más temprana
para evitar un contagio rápido comienzo
por preguntarle a mario carbonell
nuestro corresponsal en la ciudad de
mexico la percepción que hay en torno al
tema de la pandemia este país ya incluso
ha empezado a tener una apertura de la
vida social y económica con
restricciones
así es ese tema pues ha generado mucha
controversia por la postura del gobierno
la estrategia que están llevando a cabo
que uno de los puntos polémicos es el
uso del cubrebocas el propio presidente
de la república pues se ha negado
reiteradamente a usar el cubrebocas
elementos públicos argumentando que pues
no no se ha probado su eficacia en la
misma línea que el pocero ante la
pandemia lópez gatell y a contrapelo
pues de los ejemplos internacionales
esto ha generado muchas críticas en la
opinión pública otro tema es el de las
pruebas de detección de kobe con la
finalidad de contener desde un principio
el gobierno dijo que la estrategia no
iba a ser la de contención del virus y
finalmente pues los pronósticos que ha
hecho el propio responsable del manejo
de la pandemia
insisto lópez gatell que había previsto
que llegáramos a los 60.000 muertos en
el escenario catastrófico en el peor de
los escenarios hacia el mes de octubre
lo cual
pues esa cifra se rebasó ya desde el 22
de agosto entonces ciertamente ha sido
un tema recurrente y el presidente ha
dicho que no van a modificar esta
estrategia que comparado con otros
países no vamos tan mal incluso han
tenido respuesta por ejemplo del
gobierno de españa cuando quiso comparar
el manejo que se han tenido españa en
méxico de la crisis de salud también ha
expresado molestia cuando la prensa
precisamente publica la cantidad de
muertos el comparativo con otros países
con la misma cantidad de población y
bueno el presidente lo toma como
críticas de los adversarios cuando en
realidad pues mucho muchas opiniones han
vertido respecto del manejo de la
pandemia así es que en méxico el médico
mario hacia la demanda económica es
cierto si mario es que en méxico ya van
más de 600 mil casos confirmados y 64
mil más de 64 mil personas
han fallecido en toda la república
mexicana aleida su balance de la gestión
del mandatario con estas cifras y dado
el escenario que se está presentando
allí el mandatario dijo en su
intervención que al llegar al poder
había encontrado una red hospitalaria
bastante deficiente y con falta de
médicos en algunos hospitales de la
república mexicana
si lamentablemente tuvimos un escenario
catastrófico en donde había un abandono
casi total del sistema de salud se es un
robo se hizo un negocio con todo lo que
fue en la prestación de servicios de
salud la compra de medicamentos en la
comparecencia de la oficial mayor de
presidencia es un pueblo que pudimos
constatar que pues había toda una serie
de anomalías en la decisión de ica
efectos que por eso tuvimos que hacer
adecuaciones para que los contratos
fueran centralizados que eran negocios
de los gobernantes lo que se vería en
esta prestación de servicios
precisamente si la red hospitalaria está
tan deficiente y faltan los médicos y
llega una pandemia a este país porque el
el gobierno no reaccionó más rápido
previendo que su red hospitalaria no iba
a estar en las condiciones adecuadas
para hacer frente a la situación
bueno nosotros yo entiendo que se hizo
todo lo necesario en primera instancia
cuando se habilitó una comunicación muy
estrecha con toda la población para
alertar de la prevención de este virus
en diferentes modalidades orientando al
cómo se podría uno proteger en las
condiciones en las que estamos de una
falta de infraestructura de personal de
medicamentos nos dejaron el sistema de
salud entonces en varios estados tomaron
tenidas distintas de hecho hasta
empezaron a enfrentar al accidente para
no hacer valer estas medidas en la
ciudad de mexico es donde yo represento
y además estamos también en esta línea
de una prevención más profunda pues se
hizo un cierre de todas las actividades
económicas sociales de más de tres meses
entonces
está actuado conforme se pudo en cuanto
a las condiciones
encontramos el sistema pero no para como
estábamos no no creo que una vida más
una vida menos sería la claro pero pues
es lo que se pudo hacer bajo esas
situaciones marco me quedan pocos
minutos para cerrar el programa su
percepción sobre este tema del manejo de
la pandemia si santiago la estrategia ha
sido un absoluto fracaso de punta a
punta
los pronósticos las medidas iniciales y
las decisiones que se tomaron a lo largo
de estos meses muestran el fracaso en el
número de muertes que hoy nos tiene
ubicados como el décimo país con más
muertes por cada 100.000 habitantes el
gobierno confundió vidas con camas y ni
preservó las vidas ni resolvió el tema
de las camas de hospital de tal manera
que hoy estamos en una situación muy
lamentable
por las pérdidas humanas y también
porque los casos de corrupción se dieron
en los propios suministros médicos como
los que represento el hijo de manuel
bartlett director de la comisión federal
de electricidad que empezó a vender
ventiladores a precios por encima del
mercado y en condiciones de opacidad y
con una corrupción flagrante
pues se nos acaba el tiempo debo
despedir ya el programa aleida alavez en
marco adame y mario para ponerle en la
capital mexicana gracias por habernos
acompañado haber puesto aquí en
perspectiva estos tres puntos que abordó
el presidente en su informe de gestión a
usted los invito para que sigan dejando
sus comentarios a través de las redes
sociales de france24 siga con nuestra
programación
[Música]